[Música]
lo que oyen son disparos de armas
automáticas en el norte del Líbano que
tienen como objetivo las aves
migratorias cada año en primavera
millones de aves salen de África para
emigrar rumba a Europa el norte del
Líbano es uno de los corredores de aves
migratorias más importantes
nuestro observador recorre la zona a
diario para contar las aves abatidas y
rescatar aquellas que resultaron heridas
le disparan a todo lo que huele desde
las aves grandes a las pequeñas le
disparan a las águilas Los Gavilanes
los cernícalos los Pelícanos las
cigüeñas blancas las cigüeñas negras las
grullas grises lastimosamente matan
muchas aves y no hay quien los pare
nadie los detiene
disparan con armas de guerra como ak-47
m16 asval y muchas otras que se utilizan
en tiempos de guerra
un día conté 15 Pelícanos 30 cigüeñas en
una sola ciudad era impresionante que
sería mataron más de 700 cigüeñas y
Pelícanos solo para divertirse
ver
de hecho esas aves no son comestibles ni
las cigüeñas ni las rapaces
he encontrado aves muertas y heridas
muchas veces las llevo a mi centro de
rescate para hacerles una evaluación
médica
decenas de videos publicados en las
redes sociales muestran la casa de aves
que tiene lugar esta primavera en el
norte del Líbano sin embargo la ley
libanesa prohíbe la casa a menos de 500
metros de las viviendas y también la
cacería de aves migratorias silvestres
[Aplausos]
muchas de estas aves son especies
protegidas como esta cigüeña rescatada
por nuestro observador
alguien la encontró en su jardín después
de que un cazador le disparara
la tuvo en su casa unos días
le puse un yeso que estaba muy mal
colocado
todos los días nos llegan de 10 a 15
aves de casas cigüeñas Pelícanos
Lamentablemente la mayoría de ellas
quedan con alguna discapacidad física
debido a las heridas causadas por la
casa ilegal
según Michelle zaguán esta cigüeña
sobrevivirá pero pasará el resto de su
vida en un centro de rehabilitación las
aves que no puedes salvar como esta
cigüeña que tiene una pata rota no
sobrevivirán solas en la naturaleza
[Música]
en estas imágenes tomadas en Nueva del
India vemos devotos hindúes celebrando
el festival de Shack puja en aguas
cubiertas de espuma el río es el yamuna
afluente del ganges Y al igual que este
el yamuna es uno de los ríos más
sagrados del país pero también uno de
los más contaminados del mundo pancakes
cumar alias Earth water o Guerrero de la
tierra en español Lleva más de cuatro
años denunciando estos problemas
recurrentes a través de sus redes
sociales
el problema en Nueva Delhi Es que la
mayor parte del agua no se trata y las
plantas de tratamiento de agua no
funcionan correctamente lo que explica
esta contaminación cuando lavamos la
ropa el agua de nuestras casas se va por
el desagüe y luego va para el río yamuna
eso es lo que produce esta espuma
además las Industrias textiles y de
teñido dejan correr millones de litros
de agua sin tratar la dejan correr hasta
el yamuna
esa contaminación empeora por la falta
de agua en el lecho del río lo que se
debe a que esta es utilizada para el
riego la industria o el abastecimiento
de los 30 millones de habitantes de la
ciudad de Nueva Delhi el río llamó nace
considera muerto entre la presa de
guasirabat yetawa lo que ocurre entre la
presa de guasira es que no hay agua
dulce solo hay aguas residuales si uno
va al llamó una después de Nueva Delhi
no hay vida acuática en sus aguas nada
puede sobrevivir
recientemente se descubrió que el nivel
de amoniaco en el yamuna es demasiado
alto el límite de amoniaco aceptable en
el agua es de 0,5 miligramos por litro
actualmente el nivel de amoniaco en el
yamuna de Delhi supera los 5 miligramos
por litro las personas económicamente
estables no se ven afectadas pero las
que no lo son sufren escasez de agua
porque dependen de cisternas y como el
yamuna está contaminado las cisternas no
llegan las personas que viven cerca del
río yamuna tienen la piel quemada sufren
muchas enfermedades la gente es tan
devota de los ríos yamuna y ganges que
arriesgan su vida para ir a bañarse en
ellos como les rezamos a estos Ríos por
eso vamos allá consideramos que son mata
que es nuestra madre y que no nos harían
daño
esto afecta a los animales a los humanos
y a nuestra tierra
también contamina nuestra tierra Porque
los agricultores que dependen del agua
del yamuna para el riego utilizan esta
agua
estas aguas que transportan productos
químicos se utilizan para la agricultura
en noviembre de 2021 el jefe de gobierno
de la ciudad de Nueva Delhi prometió
limpiar el llamó una para 2025 y que él
mismo se bañaría en el río Pero según
nuestro observador es muy poco probable
que cumpla con su promesa
Gracias a todos nuestros observadores
por hacer posible Este programa si
ustedes desean participar enviándonos
archivos imágenes vídeos o testimonios
todos nuestros contactos aparecen en sus
pantallas Nos despedimos hoy desde la
Feria Internacional del Libro de Bogotá
Hasta pronto
[Música]